starting pitcher for the tigers is casey
mize and it's going to be a fun one to
watch tonight he's making his second
major league start first one ever here
at comerica
how about that swing and a miss
and rizzo grabs some bench for two away
roman's gonna set
that's a one two three start for casey
mize that includes a couple of
punch-outs they're gonna be facing the
right-hander alec mills two and two on
the year
come back greg maddox like fastball for
strike three
runners go 3-2 swing and a miss on the
changeup so back-to-back k's after the
consecutive singles after an inning
nothing nothing
david with those two big game-winning
hits against the cardinals last week
cubs have a three-game lead in the
division starting play tonight and that
one punched out into right center
contreras coming home and the cubs have
the lead
one to nothing here in the second here's
nico horner first and third two down
cody takes off
that ball drilled
into center and it's two nothing
bodhi will stop at third
it looked like goodrem got a glove on it
but just could not haul it in with bases
loaded here's anthony rizzo rizzo first
pitch swinging and he pops it up
room for romine and he takes care of it
kobe jones takes a strike from alec
mills
last train to clarksville fastball
strike three called
surrounded by horner and he
got him at first
dave clark immediately going with the
headset emoji down there the first base
coach i think they're going to challenge
this one
jeter jump throw there from nicole
here's a pop-up shallow right coming in
hayward and horner goes out to make
another fine play
called strike three
so far tonight he's got four strikeouts
high target from contreras up and in the
1-0 pitch swinging the line drive base
hit into right field castle will stop at
second as hayward comes up with a ball
and gets it in scope line drives single
righties two for two the tigers have the
bases loaded here's the three two on the
ground rizzo
they'll take the force at second that's
all they'll get runners at the corners
tigers have a run plated it's 2-1 cubs
david bodie will lead off the cubs
fourth inning david had a run-scoring
single his first time up cup
david bode launches and it will
go a home run to make it three to one
his rbi single got the scoring started
back in the second this time nobody on
base so he has to do it all himself but
now it's uh up to tyler to get him out
of this mess and get him back into the
dugout because this game's still young
[Applause]
grounded up the middle end of center
the drive-in horner
martin heyer goes with the lefty rizzo
says no worries i got this now you're
heading to the heart of the order javier
baez at the plate
is out in the deep right and it is gone
two-run homer for javi 6-1
he's back
that one had to feel awfully good that's
his fourth and first in a good while
five-run lead here in the fourth
swing and a miss
or strike three don't go very far when
you don't hit it
five for alec full count on romine you
think he's gonna swing right yeah he
didn't
he's not gonna walk
wow six strikeouts for mills after four
all cubs six to one throw number 69 here
to david bodie
to candelario they'll try and turn two
the hard way
and they do
inning is done
tigers still trail by five as they head
to the bottom half of the seventh a nice
job twisting it jacoby jones at the
plate
there you go jacoby lead off single for
jacoby jones his first hit of the night
stewart the left fielder
stewart launches one and that's going to
find the seats a two-run bomb for
kristen stewart the tigers have cut the
lead in half
oh boy if anybody needed that hit it's
christian stewart
hopefully that'll pick him up a little
bit
swing gonna miss on the changeup for
strike three
john schreiber is the new pitcher
baez in the air
deep left it is long gone a home run
seven to threes homered twice tonight
don't be surprised to see them coming
bunches once he gets it figured out you
know he didn't miss by much last time he
just got under the ball a little bit
last time hit a fairly deep fly ball to
left this time another no doubter
home runs number four and five for javi
tonight
deep left in the corner
[Music]
almora toward third he'll stop there
it's a double for hayward inning looking
pretty good
on the ground into left
one run in here comes hayward
he will score
david bodie has knocked in four tonight
and it's nine to three here in the night
climbing the ladder
rizzo's got it
cubs win
cubs win the final tonight 9-3 javi's
back
good start to the road trip and congrats
to the cubs organization 11 000 wins
it's a lot of w's folks